a new virus that began in China just a
few months ago has now infected the
world the World Health Organisation's
reclassification of the virus as a
pandemic for the proof of its deadly
impact we're deeply concerned both by
the alarming levels of spread and
severity and by the alarming levels of
inaction we have therefore met the
assessment that kovat 19 can be
characterized as a pandemic but what
exactly does this change mean a pandemic
is only declared when there is evidence
of transmission within the community in
more than one continent so in this case
you now have established community
transition in China and in Korea which
if you like stand for Asia and
transmission in Italy which would stand
for Europe the numbers of dead and
infected a rising worldwide here in the
UK confirmation of two more fatalities
the virus has spread to the heart of
government Health Minister Nadine Dory's
the first MP to test positive for Kovach
19 she's in self isolation and in this
tweet says she's fine my story started
showing symptoms last Thursday the same
day she attended a Downing Street event
hosted by the Prime Minister
Labour MP Rachel Maskull meant miss
stories on the same day and told us she
is also self isolating absolutely fine
myself so of course it is frustrating
but it's absolutely crucial that we
followed the advice we've got to make
sure we contain and delay the spread of
this virus and therefore if we have had
that contact making sure we contact NHS
one-one-one either online or by phone
and to seek the advice that they are
giving and to follow that advice
crucially a leaked email sent to MPs and
seen by Sky News sought to reassure
politicians fearing an outbreak at
Westminster it confirmed that Parliament
would not shut down but that could
change
ministers arriving at a coab
meeting would have been aware of the
latest covert 19 cases as the country
gears up for an inevitable surge in
cases 130 UK holidaymakers trapped in
their own coronavirus nightmare
touchdown they were among three and a
half thousand passengers trapped onboard
the Grand Princess cruise liner finding
positive cases is crucial the NHS has
stepped up its covert 19 testing program
with mobile clinics like this one in
Wolverhampton the reclassification of
covert 19 is a signal to the
international community that this deadly
virus needs a global effort to stop it
spreading any further and taking any
more lives
Ashish Joshi Sky News